مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم في حلقه
جديده من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا
عبيده نفاع
[موسيقى]
ليفربول الاخيره والانتصار التاريخي على
مانشستر يونايتد بسباعيه نظيفه مباراه
كمان شهدت انجاز تاريخي للنجمه المصري
محمد صلاح اللي وصل ل 129 هدف بالدوري
الانجليزي او بالبريميرليج مع ليفربول
ليكون الهداف التاريخي للنادي الانجليزي
وليس بالدوري الانجليزي
النسخه المحدثه من الدوري الانجليزي اللي
تم استحداثها عام 1992 مثل ما الكل بيعرف
وهاي النسخه اللي هي الان محمد صلاح
الهداف التاريخي الى ليفربول فيها
بالمقابل على مستوى الدوري الانجليزي عبر
التاريخ محمد صلاح هو رابع هداف لليفربول
حتى الان طيب شو سر تالق محمد صلاح
واستمراريته على مدار السنوات الماضي اول
سبب بكل امانه هو خروجه من المنظومه
الكرويه العربيه ان كان المصريه ولا غير
المصريه ولكن المنظومه الكرويه العربيه
بتساهم بشكل كبير بافشال اللاعب لانه
بينحط بقالب معين ضمن بيئه غير صحيه
رياضيه ولا اسلاميا وبالتالي تنتهي مسيرته
على بكير وشفنا كثير لاعبين اما تحجموا او
تقدمت امكانياتهم او انتهت مسيرتهم على
بكير لانهم وضعوا نفسهم بخلاط الكره
العربيه
فخروج محمد صلاح بدون الانضمام لقطبي
الكره المصريه الاهلي والزمالك والتاثر
بشعبيه هذين الفريقين والذهاب بعيدا
باتجاه بازل السويسري بعد الانتقال من
المقاولون العرب اثر بشكل ايجابي على
مسيره محمد صلاح لانه فهموا معنى الاحتراف
من البدايات وخلاه يروح باتجاه اوروبا من
البدايه ويتعلم كيف يتاقلم مع الظروف
الصعبه ويقوي نفسه
ذهنيا السبب الثاني وبما انه عم نحكي عن
العامل الذهني فمحمد صلاح بالروتين اليومي
عنده صباحا
قبل المباراه اذا استطاع انه يعمل يوجا
وبالاضافه طبعا للصلاه اللي بيؤديها صباحا
وبالتالي هذا الامر بخليه اكثر هدوءا
ذهنيا داخل ارضيه الملعب في يوم مباريات
وهذا عامل مهم جدا بالنسبه للاعب وخصوصا
للاعبين البريميرليج المعروف بتنافسيته
العاليه وبالتوتر الشديد اللي بيكون موجود
خلال المباريات
العامل الاخر ايضا هو عامل التغذيه لانه
بالتاكيد حفاظ محمد صلاح على بنيتو
الجسمانيه وتطويرها مش بس الحفاظ عليها
اللي بشوف محمد صلاح اليوم مش مثل اللي
بشوف محمد صلاح لما كان مع بازل او لما
كان مع روما او لما كان البنيه الجسمانيه
القوه الاحتكاكات اللياقه البدنيه السرعه
ايضا هذه عوامل كلياتها لعب فيها او لعبت
فيها التغذيه دور مهم جدا بالاضافه
للتمرينات بالجيم وتطوير وتضخيم بعض
العضلات الموجودين عند محمد صلاح وهذا
الامر اللي ساهم بشكل كبير بتطوير اداءه
داخل ارضيه الملعب العامل الفني بما انه
عم نحكي على الاداء ايضا كان عامل مهم
بالنسبه لصلاح صلاح بالبدايات كان عنده
مشكله تسجيل تخيل الان الهداف التاريخي
لليفربول كان بالبدايات عنده مشكله
بالانهاء امام المرمى كانت نقطه ضعف محمد
صلاح بتذكر بواحده من المباريات كانت بين
روما وريال مدريد كانت نقطه ضعفه هو
الانهاء امام المرمى اما الان محمد صلاح
ليثا كما يقال يعني سفاح امام المرمى
وبسجل اهداف بشكل غزير جدا وهو واحد من
افضل المهاجمين بالعالم بالاضافه لكل ذلك
طبعا فكر يورجن كلوب توظيف يورجن كلوب
لمحمد صلاح على مدار السنوات الماضي كان
مهم جدا ولعب دور بارز بابراز قوه محمد
صلاح
والعمل والشغل على نقاط قوته وتحسين نقاط
ضعفه اللي كانت موجوده العام الاخير بتطور
مستوى محمد صلاح وحفاظه على مستواه بالقمه
هو جماهير ليفربول لما الجماهير كلها
بتغني لك بالملعب اغنيه الملك المصري
الدعم الكبير اللي بتشوفه من جماهير
ليفربول لمحمد صلاح حتى باوساط المجتمع
الانجليزي بليفربول هذا امر مهم جدا
لتطوير اللاعب ولا حتى اللاعب يبقى دائما
بالقمه ويبقى دائما بقمه مستواه ويعطي
دائما جمهور ليفربول اهميته واللي بيفرقوا
عن بقيه جماهير الكره الانجليزيه
والاوروبيه انه حتى لما اللاعب بينزل
مستواه حتى لما يمر بفتره شك بكون الجمهور
دائما معه وخلفه تحت شعاري والنفر اذا هاي
اهم العوامل اللي ساهمت بوصول محمد صلاح
لهذا الانجاز وربما الانجازات تتوالى
وتستمر بحال بقي محمد صلاح مع ليفربول وقد
يصل الى نقطه لا يمكن ان نتخيلها ربما
يكون افضل لاعب في تاريخ ليفربول على
الاطلاق يوما
هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه بعض الصافره حتى
نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل
[تصفيق]